au milieu des années 90 j'ai eu la
chance de faire partie de ceux qui ont
amené internet en france et ça m'a donné
un point de vue tout à fait
extraordinaire puisque j'ai réalisé à ce
moment là que on avait peut-être moins
un changement de civilisation qui
s'opérait devant nous qu'un changement
d'espèce une évolution des espèces ce
qui m'a mis la puce à l'oreille
là-dessus tenait au fait que finalement
aujourd'hui si je mets une petite phrase
dans un forum ou si je fais un tweet ou
si je lis des tweets ou si je tag une
photo dans un réseau social et bien
immédiatement ça peut me lié par le sens
à d'autres personnes ça veut dire que
finalement nous passons notre temps à
déposer ou un suivre 17 des phéromones
sémiotique ça veut dire des bouts de
sens et avec ses bouts de sens nous nous
connectons les uns les autres et chaque
seconde on peut voir internet comme un
métier à tisser qui crée du qui crée du
lien qui crée de la relation alors pour
le meilleur et pour le pire je ne nie
pas ce qu'on va en faire de ça mais en
tout cas je pouvais à ce moment là
vraiment voir une évolution des espèces
et ça m'a donné l'envi au début des
années 2000 de tout lâcher lâché ma vie
corporate pour me consacrer à la
recherche et au développement dans
l'intelligence collective et ce dont je
ne me doutais pas à cette époque je ne
savais pas à quel point ça m'amènerait
dans une aventure bien sûr
intellectuelle existentielle mais aussi
également spirituel puisque sa touche
évidemment aux grands changements que
nous avons dans d'autres dans notre vie
alors l'intelligence collective kézaco
ça veut dire quoi
et bien déjà on peut en parler comme une
nouvelle discipline de recherche qui
vise qui explore quoi et bien
l'intelligence collective à savoir
comment le vivent social se structure et
comment il arrive à faire parfois des
organismes sociaux des sociétés à part
entière qui semble même parfois quand
elle fonctionne bien fonctionné comme
nos corps finalement l'évolution dans le
passé elle a déjà fait ça elle a mis
ensemble des cellules et des protéines
et puis plein de plein d'autres choses
des bactéries bien entendu et ce qu'ils
font encore aujourd'hui ce qui fait la
vie animale et la vie végétale et bien
il semble que ce mouvement continue et
j'ai décidé d'explorer ça alors comme
toute discipline et bien il faut
commencer par le commencement
à savoir déjà s'intéresser aux
différentes formes d'intelligence
collective qui existe et je vous propose
déjà de vous parler très rapidement très
succinctement t4 grande forme en suivant
le fil de l'évolution
à commencer par cette première forme
d'intelligence collective peut être la
plus ancienne celle qu'on appelle
l'intelligence collective en essaim
alors là vous n'avez pas un essaim de
poissons vous avez un banc de poissons
mais en tout cas qui va mettre un grand
nombre d'individus ensemble quand je dis
individu peut s'agir de fourmies il peut
s'agir de bison donc un grand troupeau
un grand nuage d'oiseaux des abeilles
bien entendu les insectes sociaux et à
chaque fois on à ce point commun que on
a un grand groupe d'individus ensemble
et avec au niveau individus de
l'individu une marge de manoeuvre plutôt
restreinte sur par design à la fourmi
ouvrière c'est faire un certain nombre
de choses et pas d'autres soit par
circonstances voyez le poisson ici dans
ce dans ce banc de poissons y suit le et
suit le banc et il fait pas grand chose
d'autre et pourtant au niveau collectif
on peut avoir une intelligence
émergentes extraordinaire quoi de plus
intelligent qu'une fourmilière par
exemple qui résout des problèmes
incroyable et qui s'adapte sans cesse à
des environnements changeants et
complexe alors revenons nous de ce type
d'intelligence collective nous mêmes eh
bien je veux dire que ça caractérise un
petit peu notre espèce enfin elle ne se
fonde pas là dessus mais nous traversons
ce genre de situation de temps en temps
notamment par exemple vous avez une
magnifique photo ici du marathon de new
york
vous avez dix mille personnes qui se
mettent à courir ensemble ou qui
pourraient manifester et on a là ce
contexte d'intelligence collective
origines pardon cette intelligence
collective en essaims on connaît aussi
tous ce genre de situation un petit peu
moins rigolote dans laquelle on se
trouve dans nos voitures en train de
râler avec une marge de manoeuvre là
aussi plutôt restreinte et pourtant au
niveau collectif
ça permet de remplir et de vider une
ville chaque jour essayer de planifier
sa vous voyez qu'au niveau émergents
peut avoir des propriétés tout à fait
intéressante
alors je vous disais que nous on vient
pas de 7 ce type d'intelligence
collective nous venons nous venons de ça
parce qu'on va appeler la deuxième forme
d'intelligence collective l'intelligence
collective originel pourquoi parce qu'on
vient de là et là qui fonctionne un peu
al'inverse de la précédente puisque nous
avons un petit groupe d'individus mais
qui en soi une grande marge de manoeuvre
ils ont une grande individuation on
imagine bien que
c'est s'agit ici c'est faire beaucoup
beaucoup plus de choses que les insectes
sociaux ou que notre poisson dans le
banc de poissons alors cette
intelligence collective originel et bien
on peut très vite là la comprendre par
empathie l'âge et j'ai mis cette photo
que j'adore d'un groupe de jazz on voit
tout de suite ce qui se passe on a nos
cerveaux au câble et pour ça nous avons
notre corps conçue pour ça pour
comprendre et bien ce phénomène de
connexion on voit tout de suite que
chaque joueur fonctionne avec les autres
joueurs les autres musiciens et qu' il y
a un tout qui émerge qu'on appelle le
groupe de jazz néanmoins l'évolution a
continué et lorsqu'il s'agit de faire
grandir tout ça puisque ça reste
cantonnée à des petits groupes et bien
l'évolution à créer quelque chose
d'unique qu'on ne trouve pas celle dans
le monde animal mais uniquement chez le
monde humain ce qu'on appelle la
troisième forme d'intelligence
collective on appelle l'intelligence
collective pyramidale qui a vu le jour
avec l'invention de l'écriture qui a
permis de sortir des traditions orales
pour que le message
le signal puissent voyager et dans
l'espace et dans le temps
et là tout d'un coup ça a permis
l'émergence de grands collectifs avec
différentes caractéristiques notamment
des pouvoirs centralisés voire très
centralisé dans toutes les premières
civilisations on a des dieux vivants et
puis des castes un système de castes
avec ou de classes sociales avec des
chaînes de commandement et puis aussi
une répartition tout à fait inégale des
ressources en particulier des ressources
financières puisqu'on trouve toujours
évidemment beaucoup plus de
concentration d'argent ou de monnaie à
la tête plutôt que à la base
et puis belle évolution ne s'arrête pas
là d' même si nous vivons encore
aujourd'hui dans un monde
essentiellement constitué l'intelligence
collective pyramidale nous entrons dans
cette nouvelle ère que j'explore celle
de l'internet
là nous avons d'ailleurs une photo déjà
ses anciennes de l'internet ou la
structure sociale et humaine se trouve
beaucoup plus distribué on a des
structures distribué rhizomatique ça
fonctionne un peu comme le rhizome des
ferait sous nos sous nos pieds ou comme
nos cerveaux donc distribué
décentralisée pair à pair innovations
vertes etc etc
alors voilà je vous ai vraiment scanner
très très vite ces quatre grandes formes
d'intelligence collective avec
maintenant une question pour ça évolue
reste pas
toujours pareil eh bien on remarque de
toute façon dans l'évolution du vivant
qu il ya quoi qui fait changer un
système bien quoi qui fait changer la
vie est bien en général quand une espèce
marche elle se reproduit elles se
multiplient jusqu'à finalement entré
dans un mécanisme d'étouffement qui va
générer une explosion de complexité et
en gros la forme d'avant ne suffit plus
soit ça s'effondre soit ça atteint un
nouveau seuil de complexité et bien si
on regarde l'histoire de l'intelligence
collective humaine dont je démarre sur
l'intelligence collective humaine
originel on a connu nous l'humanité une
première très grande crise alors on l'a
pas vu parce que elle a sévi cette crise
sur des milliers d'années mais lorsque
l'humain a commencé à se sédentariser
autrement dit il a déployé l'agriculture
les premières villes ont commencé à
apparaître et nous avons eu une
explosion de complexité à ce moment là
qui fait que la tradition orale et la
proximité ne suffisait plus voyez ici
dans cette dans cette image là vous avez
une extraordinaire propriété
d'intelligence collective je vais mettre
un jeu mettre un gros mot dessus qu'on
appelle l'optisme du grès colosse
holistique le tout est aux petits sme ce
groupe là ils marchent ce groupe de jazz
parce que chaque joueur non seulement il
a son individuation qui sait bien jouer
de son instrument mais en plus il a
cette capacité de se représenter le tout
le groupe de jazz où l'équipe de sport
ou le comité de direction peu importe
mais on a cette représentation du tout
qui se met en place
si on augmente le nombre est bien ça
marche plus l'optisme nous le perdons et
nous devons passer à une autre structure
ici évidemment l'orchestré symphonique
où l'orchestré poly harmonique ou là on
va avoir évidemment des personnes qui
vont commencer à prendre le commandement
par nécessité pour faire les grandes
choses et cette situation donc cette
transition a eu lieu comme réponse à une
première grande crise avec l'invention
de l'écriture et qui a permis justement
je vous disais de déployer tout ça et
bien aujourd'hui on vit une deuxième
grande crise
l'intelligence collective pyramidale
qu'on appelle panoptique donc ça veut
dire où vous avez tout en å quelqu'un
qui a la vision d'ensemble mais qui ne
voient pas le détail où tout en bas vous
avez les gens qui ont la vision du
détail mais pas la vision d'ensemble
ça a marché pendant très longtemps mais
aujourd'hui et bien ça a explosé partout
et ça crée une nouvelle un nouveau
niveau de complexité en générant aussi
plein de plein de mots et bien la
pollution le réchauffement climatique
les inégalités sociales les guerres de
territoire les guerres pour la pour la
rareté les choses rares dans le monde et
c'est la concentration de la richesse
tout ça finalement relève de problèmes
créés par cet écosystème qui a émergé et
qui s'étouffe aujourd'hui sur lui-même
et la bonne nouvelle dans tout ça et
bien ça donne naissance évidemment à
cette nouvelle forme d'intelligence
collective je vous disais olomide al
olomide al quatrième forme du grec au
laus holistique et qui la permet de
relier le local au global le pair à pair
l'innovation ouverte l'arrivée de
l'imprimante 3d tout ce qui touche aussi
à l'humain augmenté connectés et cetera
et encore une fois pour le meilleur et
pour le pire
je n'ai pas d'idéologie gêne au genou
bien pas vendre des lendemains qui
chantent il ya en tout cas des
nouveautés qui se font alors cette
intelligence collective olomide al je
pourrais vous en parlait comme beaucoup
le font à savoir effectivement décrire
les futurs modèles économiques la
société post argent j'en parle souvent
l'argent servait très bien pour
l'intelligence collective pyramidale
mais ça ne convient plus lorsqu'on veut
entrer dans une économie du partage des
ressources etc
je pourrais vous en parler au niveau de
la délocalisation de la production etc
et cetera mais j'ai envie d'aborder sa
sur un autre plan et là c'est vraiment
la quintessence de mes recherches de ces
dernières années parce que je me disais
ok on attend d'en savoir toujours les
choses sur l'extérieur des questions
d'écologie comment on va résoudre tel ou
tel problème et on oublie la question de
l'intérieur ça veut dire comment nous en
tant que personne nous allons nous
transformer quelle conscience vint
habiter si j'évolue quelle conscience va
nous habiter
nous évoluons autres dit finalement nous
existons tous comme des hologrammes de
la société la société l existant mois
elles arrivent par mois et je la
reproduis je la reproduis comment
justement est bien là par exemple je
vous parle français je vous parle donc
une langue et j'utilise un objet
collectif qu'on appelle une langue une
langue quand on regarde son histoire
elle fonctionne comme une sédimentation
de représentation du monde à des époques
diverses et variées qui va du passé très
lointain jusqu'au présent mais aucune
langue au monde qu'il s'agisse de
français ou de chinois ne me permettra
de me représenter de me donner une
expérience de conscience de demain
aucune au monde et je pourrais dire la
même chose pour les codes sociaux les
codes sociaux existent depuis le passé
jusqu'à maintenant ils servent à
perpétuer et à reproduire une société
mais il ne me rends pas me servir si je
souhaite évoluer donc dans mes
recherches j'ai commencé à me poser la
question me dire tiens par exemple dans
la langue dire quoi aujourd'hui alors je
parle français je parle couramment
l'anglais le cheval pas trop mal
l'espagnol
je me concentre sur le français et
l'anglais je me dis tiens il ya quoi
dans ces deux langues qui se ressemblent
qui aujourd'hui peuvent limiter et j'ai
découvert un certain nombre de choses et
notamment j'ai fait un choix alors je ne
sais pas si vous l'avez vu aussi vous
l'avez ressenti je parle un français
différents qu'on appelle le f primes
prime pour dériver du français f pour le
français si je parlais anglais je
parlerai ibrahim et j'ai décidé de
supprimer le verbe être sauf erreur de
ma part je n'ai pas utilisé cette
auxiliaire le verbe être dans mes
phrases depuis que je vous parle alors
pourquoi je m'amuserai à faire quelque
chose comme ça et quel lien avec
l'intelligence collective
je lisais une langue il s'agit d'un
objet collectif si je dis par exemple à
belfort est une ville froide
bon je vous laisse pas le choix je vous
dis c'est comme ça
ça veut dire première chose que je vous
impose une réalité qui que je vis comme
absolu et moi même je ne me connecte pas
à moi même comme créateur de cette
expérience
ça veut dire que j'utilise la forme
ordinaire du langage pour dire les
choses qui sont ou ne sont pas
desquelles je me détache ne me vois plus
moi même comme observateur et comme
créateur de cette expérience et je vous
impose cette expérience comme une
expérience qui n'a rien à voir avec moi
vous voyez déjà le fait de ne plus
utiliser verbe être me permet de dire
les voilà je ressens telle ou telle
chose je vois telle ou telle chose j'ai
telle ou telle expérience mais je ne
vais plus dire les choses sont ou ne
sont pas deuxième point en retirant le
verbe être vous savez être ne pas être
tout bio not to be
je décris si j'ai utilisé le verbe être
j'ai décrit le monde de façon
aristotélicienne ça veut dire donc de
manière binaire les chaussures ne sont
pas il me semble que la réalité nous
permet nous offre effectivement un
continuum beaucoup plus grande
impermanence de choses qui se transforme
et en n'utilisant pas le verbe être ça
m'a permis de faire évoluer le langage
ça n'a pas tout résolu mais rien que cet
exemple là ce tout petit pas m'a demandé
de faire descendre dans le corps une
pratique je lire un très rigoureuse et
qui a changé non seulement mon propre
narratif pour moi même mais aussi les
relations avec les autres je prends un
autre exemple les codes sociaux
aucun code social n'existe là par hasard
la façon dont on dit bonjour la façon
dont nous mangeons et cetera tout ce que
nous faisons nos postures ont un rôle
qui perpétue le passé et le présent
j'ai décidé dans ma vie que l'or dans
une conversation je parlerai toujours
après une longue respiration
bon je peux vous dire que le temps je
fasse la respiration en a plein d'autres
qui ont répondu avant moi alors ça fait
quoi bien ça fait que je parle peu sauf
quand on me le demande je parle toujours
avec la permission
eh bien rien que ça en désactivant ce
code social en changeant j'ai changé
quelque chose de l'ordre du collectif
les codes sociaux et ça m'a permis déjà
de vivre une vie tout à fait différente
d'avant je veux dire on écoute
certainement beaucoup plus aujourd'hui
et surtout je vois tous les gens qui
adoptent ce mode de fonctionnement
les collectifs qui adoptent ce mode de
fonctionnement qui se transforme alors
je pourrais continuer comme ça sur des
tas de sur des tas d'exemples je
pourrais pas vous parler d'alimentation
je pourrais vous parler d'économie aussi
j'ai choisi de vivre dans l'économie du
don par exemple et là aussi ça change
encore des choses beaucoup beaucoup de
choses
ce que je veux vous dire peut-être
l'invitation que j'ai de vous et de nous
questionner qu avons-nous envie de
changer dans notre corps dans notre
corps ici et maintenant
parce que la société et le collectif
vivant nous ici et maintenant et nous
pouvons changer
merci beaucoup